Anybody ever ask you to send
them sexy pictures?
I might be a victim.
Oh shit.
I'm definitely--
Whoever I
send sexy pictures to,
they're the victim.
What do they ask for?
We're trying to, like, get a
general consensus of,
like, what kind
of sexy pics guys ask for.
Um, I guess ass, titties,
I don't know.
Ass and titties,
ass, ass and titties.
Has a guy ever asked you to
send him a sexy pic?
Yes.
Yeah.
Did you?
It takes like a hundred shots
to get the right one.
You should
just do what I do.
Only do it without your
head in them.
Yes, yes.
Right?
What are you?
Pisces.
No, I mean, what race?
Turkish.
Did you ever send a picture of
your penis to anybody?
No?
That is such a yes!
Oh my gosh.
I caved in, it was
too much peer pressure,
I had to do it.
Why, she was
like, send me a picture
of your Turkish
delight?
Pretty much.
I've never sent a sexy
picture of myself.
You've never sent somebody
a picture of your boobs
or anything?
No, God, no, never.
What about
your butthole?
You know, I don't think I've
ever even seen my butthole.
You've never
seen your butthole ?
No.
Can I just tell you
something... don't look.